hello everyone i'm rod ferguson and i'm
joe shelley
now as diablo 4 marches towards its
launch next year we're excited to
announce that we'll soon be entering a
new testing phase an end game closed
beta focused on everything that happens
after you finish the epic campaign since
it's a closed beta we'll be directly
inviting a large number of people using
gameplay data to find players who have
recently spent significant time in
diablo end-game experiences these
players will give us feedback on end
game features like pvp nightmare
dungeons whispers of the dead and our
newest feature hell tied
to be eligible to receive our invite
make sure you check out our latest blog
for instructions
and don't worry if you're not invited
public testing phases will come early
next year
now participants in the end game beta
will be under nda so they won't be able
to discuss it publicly but this feedback
is critical to ensuring sanctuary is an
exciting place to slay demons long after
the campaign is over and on behalf of
the diablo 14 i want to say thanks for
your support and we'll have even more
news to share later this year so stay
tuned and in the meantime hail lilith
blessed mother
[Music]